hey y'all it's andrew cash here and this
time today's video i'm going to be going
over forecasting with profit
so i've made a few videos on forecasting
and i wasn't very happy or happy about
the types of content i created through
it
just because
um oftentimes i couldn't find a good
data set for it and also it really
didn't represent what i think is modern
forecasting
so in my previous forecasting videos
with like i think model time or fable
i was mostly going like over arimas or
arma models
but now uh since i've done a decent
amount of forecasting i actually don't
do these traditional or ema forecasting
models instead i actually use profit in
fact i kind of recommend that we should
basically always be using profit
unless if you have some specific thing
that you want to really work on but i
figured i'd go over profit and also
using kind of the tidy models
infrastructure or framework around it
so i figured this would be kind of a
short quick video going over you know
how simple it is to
use profit to forecast data
so i'm gonna open up a our markdown
document i'll say uh
uh tidy tuesday uh profit
okay and um i am actually using their
data set
um from profit
so let me
load that in
and it's called the uh it's called
example retail sales
um okay
so this
data set i believe doesn't have any
other exogenous variables so i think
we're just obviously predicting some
type of retail sales um there's a date
com which is called ds and a
y com or a column where we're trying to
predict i'm assuming like their
monthly retail sales
um one package i actually like using
when i'm doing forecasting is loading in
the lubradate package
and this comes with like some nice
helper date functions
so
right now i'm just gonna create a little
tester
and i'm going to create a as uh
as a date right and let's see if that
actually do it
she doesn't
so we can just do month
a day
and a year
right as that
as that date
right so month yeah there you go cool
so we have our date
um and i'm going to say clean df
and let's actually do some plots
so just do a simple line chart
and we can see we have a nice little
um trend
with our sales uh obviously we can see
like some type of monthly component or
some type of seasonal component but
overall
our average uh monthly sales are is also
increasing
and that's actually something we kind of
see a lot um when we're doing some
forecasting so i think when people want
to do some type of forecasting problem
is generally with like some type of
sales or products
or views and stuff like that and
generally that type of stuff that we're
trying to forecast is actually going to
be moving or non-stationary
and that's actually kind of a problem
with things like arimas where we kind of
have an assumption that it's
non-stationary or where the average
value
or the like the average is not changing
if i add like a i don't know like a you
know smooth
you know and just do that we can see
that
obviously you know the average with the
linear model is saying that this trend
is increasing through time
so that can be a problem if we're trying
to forecast this type of stuff
luckily with profit we don't actually
have to have an assumption of stationary
non-stationary data it's kind of baked
into it
in fact we actually can change our our
specific methods for
um how we want to assess the trend but
let's actually go in and see what we
would want to do uh when we're
approaching like a time series problem
so
one of the things that we can think
about uh when we're working our clean d
up is if we did a basic
um uh split so if i want to do like a
uh wrong way wrong split it's a wrong uh
split
and say initial
initial
oh oops did i not get to anyone else oh
i forgot to do tiny models
okay geez okay uh so if i do it an
initial
split and we do our cleaned
df
if we look at our actual training test
datas so if we do a training
wrong split
wrong
split
right and then we can say like type
equal to train
and we'll just kind of
do that
and i'm going to basically combine these
up splits
with the respective training test sets
so i'm going to do that
test cool
and we're going to make the same plots
right we can see that this actually
isn't good for our are the types of um
data that we're working with so
you know generally we want to have
randomly sample data sets so we don't
have any um problems we can't have a
good representative you know features
for our models but when we're dealing
with these um time series problems
we can't split it
in
uh the traditional way you know we
always have to think of a time component
and that's where we really need to think
about is like data leakage so if i
created like a generic linear model i'm
sure it would really quickly overfit
because we have some we have some data
leakage where we can have access to
future data um while also trying to
predict you know something less uh in
the future
so luckily uh tiny model is kind of
aware of this so we actually have a
initial
time splits
um
so instead of doing that
uh uh was it to clean df
right we'll do the same thing
so
we'll say
correct
splits
and then we'll just uh
do that
so this is the correct way to split your
data because it's kind of taking
uh if we say
arrange by uh ds
we can see that now it's doing what we
wanted to where we're we're training a
model
with
data with uh with data that's not in the
test data set for that time period
uh so that way we don't have any data
leakage and one thing that i kind of
would want to say is that you know just
because you're not doing it a direct
forecasting problem you know just
because you're not forecasting you know
a univariate time series where it's just
like some type of sales um it's still
useful to think about when you're
assessing your features so
um when i'm creating some models i
generally will look at these features
that i'm using such as like age stuff
like that and say is there like a time
component that i'm you know missing out
on that's causing leakage
um so it's good to kind of think think
about that so oftentimes you actually
might be using like a a initial time
split that doesn't have directly like a
day component that you want to use so
um that's always a good thing to use um
but let's actually go with profit where
we can actually do a few different
things so
right now what i want to do is just show
everyone you know what does profit look
like what's the workflow for it so
generally when you're creating a
forecast uh you want to give it the data
set
so we're going to give it a clean df
assume it's arranged
in the correct order from date
and what's interesting about uh uh like
forecast is that you're you're generally
always refitting it to basically predict
the next period
so you know right now we have
uh this oops
this data set if we
do it so this is like for 2016. so for
like uh
uh jennifer was in like in the next few
months we'd be refitting it once we
observed more data because that's how it
kind of understands how to forecast the
next uh next period um
so what's kind of useful about profit is
once we have our model we actually use
that model to create what we want to
forecast so in this case we're going to
use the make
future data frame and this is
essentially the periods that we want to
forecast in the future
so we pass it the model which is m
our periods
and with the periods we can say okay
maybe we want to forecast like six
months out
um we have to also just specify our
period so obviously right here they have
day week month quarter year you and but
you can also go like seconds minutes
hours
um in this case we want to do
month
and lastly we have include history
i'm just going to include the history
right now
um and what we call this usually is the
future
and then you can make your forecast by
just using the simple predict
the m and
future because you're using your model
and your
you know essentially your data set that
you want to predict on
and we usually call that uh forecast
so if we look at our forecast
you can see we actually have a lot of
stuff we have our time our trend our
additive trends our yearly components
stuff like that and then we also have
our lower and upper bound and then our
actual prediction
it's actually nice if we have a plot uh
what is it called a profit uh plot
components
and then forecast
so if we do that probably plot
components we can see
uh we have our like our uh you know
trend component so we can see what's
driving our trend uh when you see like
our deseasonalized um stuff
you can also i think just plot out
uh m and forecast right
and then right here we can see that you
know it's fitting
uh
it's oops i actually know it's fitting
the
model and it's also showing what it was
seeing
um from the past data sets or best past
uh observations
so we see that it fits it pretty well
and this is what we're trying to
forecast right over here
and yeah it looks it makes sense it
looks nice this data set is extremely
like
seasonal it's ext and it's pretty
consistent with the seasonality so this
is a perfect data set for our model to
run on
one thing that we also want to look at
so not only do we want to look at like
our
our components right here that we're
forecasting but we also can add
um our change points to the
plot and this is basically saying like
when we're when we're creating our
models or our forecasts where is it
seeing a change in the trend
and that can help diagnostic diagnose
things where hey maybe our model is
picking up something weird that we don't
want to maybe we should do some like
regularization and change that or reduce
the amount of change points or hey we
can see that there's a change point and
that's actually making a lot of sense
where where else do we see a change
point that maybe the model is not
picking up
um so right here um
profit again is pretty useful since it
kind of can automatic it automatically
detects it um which requires basically
little to no tuning at all
but it's also nice that
what's also nice about profit is that we
can actually specify specific change
points in the future so if we're
expecting you know some crazy monthly or
marketing campaign for a product we can
we can basically say okay
model um this thing uh the thing that
we're trying to forecast right now it's
gonna have a change and probably can
hopefully an increase in like say like
product sales so for this we could say
like we're gonna run a crazy black
friday sale and we're gonna push all of
our sales people we're going to increase
huge commissions on it so they should be
pushing out a lot of the product um we
can actually anticipate that and put
that into the model
um pretty quickly
um so let's actually go over um how
would we like tune a model if we uh kind
of want to start doing that
so first we can see our actual
components right here we have like our
change points our n dot chain points and
stuff like that in general uh you can
change your uh scale
so uh you can change your when we do a
change point
so there's three things we really want
to change change point prior scale i'll
just say 10.
um season seasonality prior skill which
i'll say 10
and a holidays prior scale
um there are a few other components too
so in case we want to add in our
seasonality mode
we can have an additive or
multiplicative
in this case uh we actually might want
to consider uh changing it right um
because it turns a little bit different
but in general the three points you want
to add in are your change point prior
scale seasonality prior scale and
holiday prior scale um and how i
remember it is it's always like a prior
scale and then seasonality mode is
something where you kind of want to look
at the data set
and change it yourself um you can also
do the change points
um
so change points is the
oops change points is like a vector of
dates so that is where you would
basically be inputting um future
um
uh trend changes that you're going to
anticipate so like if you're doing some
type of huge uh change in like a
business uh that's where you would be
putting it into
so again that's pretty easy to do
but let's actually go over say how we
would change
um
our models
or just kind of see say like how would
we assess our models um in uh in a you
know in a machine learning framework so
you know when we're looking at our our
data set right here we can see that we
have our terrain and test set but you
know one of the things we want to think
about is like well what if we want to
try multiple parameters right um
and it doesn't seem the best way to do
it if we want to just assess it on this
data set
or on this test set right here you know
it'd be nice to be able to have you know
multiple uh you know folds to tune a a
model and assess its uh
performance
um luckily we actually have that with
the uh
tidy models and it's called rolling
origin
um
and with rolling origin we have our data
our initial and our assess the default
is cumulative but what it's basically
saying is uh we can have essentially
a kind of a cumulative
data set
so in this case uh if we can say like we
want to take you know this from 2005
and uh older
we'll train uh we'll use that data set
and then we'll also predict for the next
year
so i'm just gonna go
do this right now so we'll say initial
uh we'll say give it a year and assess
we'll give it you know six months
and if we uh if i do a train
a map splits an analysis
uh test equals map splits assessment
and i'll do a pivot longer
just so i can show you guys what it
looks like
okay
let's see that looks like and then i can
do a uh uh maybe i'll do a
um
and then i'll say filter
let me count the id first
okay so then i'll say filter uh
filter id is in
slice 001
slice 0 2
slice 03
right cool
cool
and now you can see kind of an example
of this where it's essentially rolling
it
it's saying like first our first uh data
set we'll have 52
um samples and then we'll increase it
and we'll assess the next six uh six
periods
so right there you can see how it's
changing
um stuff like that
um again
if we count our ids we can see that it's
increment uh increasing by one so it's
saying like we're going to have these 58
uh
or 52 uh
and yeah 58 uh samples that we're trying
to predict on or train and predict on uh
and then we'll go up by one more
increment and what 59. we'll go up one
more 60 and it'll go on and go on and go
on
so as you see that's pretty useful for
what we're doing so we essentially have
that that many um
there also are different ways to do it
so instead of just having rolling origin
where it's doing it by one period
um we can also do a
uh was a slide
siding period oops
sliding period
in this case we can kind of have it by
obviously a period
so if we want to do say like uh
the sliding period
um our index is our you know
essentially what we're going to be
sorting or kind of being basing our
period on
and then we could say our period
which could be i think
let's see
we'll say like year
and it'll look back
oops look back
uh can be like infinity intercess like
stop can be i don't like one
right
so now we have like i don't know um we
have a different way to sample it um in
that case it's more by a year than by
index
um but you can see that you know there's
different ways to skin a cat for it and
there's also sliding
index which is more about like you know
the numbers and stuff like that so if
you want to specify a certain amount
but
um again nothing too interesting maybe i
can show you guys a
uh
train data
because map splits training
or it's uh analysis
now test data
assessments
do another thing right there
filter id
is in c
slice
a one
slice o2
slice o3
a nest
and we'll do the same plots
all right so you can see it's going by a
year
um
so yeah again
uh this might be a lot of stuff but the
functions are pretty self-explanatory um
i think the trick that i learned from it
is using lookback as an infiniti but
let's actually go over training
a model and then going over some model
metrics for first thing so
in this case i'll probably just do the
this thing right here
um just because it's like 24 so let's
say like a uh time
i'll say time series k folds
right
so now that we have our time series k
folds
uh we can tune two models so i'll just
create a helper function say
um
tune profit
function splits
and we'll just do the same thing so
train data can be like
uh uh analysis splits
s data equals assessment
splits
and then our profit model will be
that df equals
train data
and then i'll be like our
m1
and our trend will be seasonality will
be
uh
additive
okay so we have that model
um and then we do m2
which would be
uh
how do you spell it
which is uh
season now
he's in high mode
and then we can do a future
make future data frame
uh m1 periods it's equal to and row test
data
freak is weak
and then we'll say include history
equals false
and then we can do our predictions so
predict
m1
future
uh
and what i always do is just select the
yes and y hat
or the date and the prediction and we'll
do it with the other model
right uh in this case we can do a few
different ways to do it uh i'll just
make this more of like a
a tidy way so i'll say type is equal to
additive
and
that type is multiplicative
and
we'll just bind the rows
and put that in
and lastly we'll left join
our test data
i it's uh by the date
cool
and obviously there are different ways
to do this so we could create a generic
tuner function so like tune
profit
uh
like
two
functions
splits
and then it will say like season
type
right and then we can just uh
do that and switch out with the m2
seasonality mode to season type
uh and then we'll just do like i don't
know
do that
and then
do that
so right here again
different ways to do it
um
but
oops but you can see that you know both
ways can do
the same thing however i'm kind of more
har hard coding it just because you know
i know what seasonality or what primers
i want to tune but again you can just do
it this way it's cleaner but it depends
on like i guess the uh
how you want to do it
but we'll probably just do some profit
because it seems like the easiest thing
to do
and we'll use our time series cam fold
so say
time series i'll say ts tune
map the a function or map the splits to
tune profit
and we can get the results right there
and we'll wait
we'll get some different seasonalities
coming in
okay it should be
hopefully it'll be done soon
uh another thing that we could could
have done is basically added added in a
progress bar
um but
let's see your time series capable it's
24
but yeah we got we got everything cool
so you're gonna get some of these errors
where it's like uh the seasonality is
different
um you can say like suppress messages or
suppress warnings um and get and you
know prevent those from coming out
so i just say select id and res finesse
res
oops
uh-oh
assessment splits it's here
assessment
ooh did i uh let's see here
look uh splits
one
analysis
and then we'll do this one too where we
do assessment
1993 yeah that makes sense so web 9193
date 1992.
okay
about
two
yeah 24 1992 to 1993.
okay what's going on here
um
so it's saying predict m select dsy hat
mutate type
test data
uh it's here
tune profit
uh that's a little odd all right
time series k folds is clean df
dsy hat range by ds period as year look
back to infinity
um okay i'll just do a uh
bind columns
let's do this again let's do
that and profit and we'll do it one more
time
in fact actually i'll do a uh
a slice
ale
n equals 10.
yep
yes tune
and then we have what is going on here
oh it's not lining up okay that's
interesting
um okay
what's your test data is that
oh freak is weak it's a month that's why
okay
that's just a little typo because i
usually do with uh use weekly data
and i totally forgot that this is not
weekly
so we can do that uh brick month
do it again sorry about that but this is
kind of a good video to highlight um
just some live more live coding and uh
find out where i was making the errors
and stuff like that so um
okay
cool
so now we have our uh data set um
one thing i actually do like doing is i
like grouping by id and the type or the
parameters
arranging by the
uh the date and also creating like a
forecast
field
this is assessing like how far out our
forecast is
the forecast is equal to row number
right
so after that we can use our forecast
oops forecast
type d s y hat and y
and there are different ways that we can
assess this so
one thing we can do is just do a group
by forecast type
and then we can do a you know rmse
uh truth equals y estimate equals y hat
and we can assess that through saying
like
you know uh group by
forecast you know slice min
estimate
right and kind of count that we can see
that our multiplicative has less error
but another thing that i like to do is
at the end day i like to try to beat a
specific baseline
so in this case when we're doing um this
um
with forecasting it's generally nice to
have a baseline um in like
classification it's saying like you know
if you if you predict the uh
the the the class with the highest
frequencies um
so
the baseline for that is actually like
naive forecasts so with the naive
forecast you're just predicting the
previous um period
um so we can actually do that pretty
simply by going to let's say you're
clean df
um i'll just create a naive right there
so mutate naive equals
lag y
n equals one order by yes
drop that name
look yes and naive so this is a weekly
naive or a monthly naive uh forecast
so we'll just do a left join
i equals
yes
um yeah it's right there
so this is essentially what uh what we
can do
and we can use what's called the mean
absolute scaled error which is the mean
absolute error for your forecast
uh divided by the mean absolute error of
a naive forecast um i like to do it this
way just because we have a little bit
more control over
um saying what counts as a naive
forecast so
there are different ways to do it um for
me right now i'm just doing a simple you
know naive forecast where
you assume that you can just predict um
the previous month's data but if we're
predicting you know six months out you
don't actually have you know say if i
want to predict in december i don't have
uh november's data
so
you know how you can say like what is
our our lagged or what's the uh
the naive value that we're gonna use to
forecast uh can just depend on on what
you're gonna do so
in this case we're just gonna do the
most um conservative amount where we're
basically gonna give our naive forecast
the most power where essentially the
naive forecast is kind of doing some
data peaking
but there's also ways where we can do
like
um
uh some other things where like we can
say
um
uh we can do like a group by the id and
stuff like that and select you know the
most recent month as a naive value but
what is it do it like this so forecast
type
summarize m a e mean absolute
um y hat minus y by mean absolute
naive minus
y
so right now we're calculating the mean
absolute scale there
and we can see that
you know maybe we do a
pivot
wider
names from type values
from equals mse
and just do like a comparison plot or
something so x equals say additive y
equals multiplicative
gm
tab line or like a little y equals mx
plus b line uh gm point and then a uh
chord is of
observer spread
so we can see you know
where our uh
our forecasts are are doing well and
stuff like that
um cool
so let's do that
uh mean absolutes get here
and for this
for this case i'll just do like maybe a
group by type and get the like median
uh mean absolute uh scale there so say
median equals median
and see
and we see our multiplicative uh has a
slight edge on that and that kind of
makes sense
um again we can also do another way to
do the uh how we assess a uh
a naive forecast so
uh instead of this we'll just do an id
right
um
and we'll just say uh oops
so right here we can say like
we'll group by our id and our
uh
our id and our type and we'll say our
date is like ds
equals
we'll say our joined or naive date
is our min ds
right minus month
uh one
right so if we go right here let's say
range by id and yes
uh we
yeah we can see like so this is the
month that we saw
but our naive date is this so this will
join basically our naive
um forecast values
onto
oops
on to uh our naive date so
you just do that right here
and instead of joining it by d yes we'll
say
naive
d s is equal to
yes
oops
uh oh god
ungroup
oh that's why
okay so that way we have like a more uh
a more realistic naive value
and then we can do the same thing what
we did right here
um so we can just do a group by forecast
right and we can get you know some of
our forecasts
right and that makes sense because now
our mean absolute scale there has
improved a little bit better
and then our naive because our we're
using a different uh
threshold for the for the forecast
okay
um so let's actually look at our final
models
and see how it compares so we'll make a
little
profit model
actually i got an idea i'll go back up
here
and we'll grab the
profit
right so this is our original
forecast and this is the one that we
found that had a slightly better
um uh performance
so let's say a multiplicative
right so you can see it's adding a
little bit more change points but it
looks like it's fitting a little bit
nicer
yeah um that was basically it for this
video i know you know we had some
problems with the joining and understand
you know the frequency of the periods
but
um this is a pretty straightforward way
of how to do most time series
forecasting problems uh you will rise
you will get uh you know some more
complexities with like adding you know
exogenous variables um looking at you
know specific holiday effects stuff like
that but
we're just like assessing a basic
forecast
i think profit has a lot of cool and
useful tools and we can also utilize uh
tidy models to deal with some of these
more fancier resampling methods for time
series components so it's pretty good to
have at least some of these stuff in
your arsenal regardless if you do a lot
of forecasting or not
with that being said i'll see you guys
next time and tidy on